[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur le non pas sur le
plateau d' interdit d'attaquer l'homme
et chez moi pour filmant oblige nous
allons nous entretenir aujourd'hui de la
crise du corps d'un virus avec à libéral
si nicolas about qui vient publier deux
livres l'alertent démocratique aux
édition de l'observatoire et le monde
selon tocqueville chez tallandier y
avait quelques journalistes militants de
la décroissance juliette duquenne qui a
créé avec pierre rabhi aux éditions du
châtelet aux presses du châtelet la
collection canada
leur dernière parution s'intitule vivre
mieux sans croissance alors nicolas mas
bonjour dans votre avant de parler de
tocqueville avant de parler de la verte
démocratique on vit quand même quelque
chose d'assez exceptionnel pour la
première fois dans l'histoire me
semble-t-il
on a mis à l'arrêt une grande partie de
notre économie pas seulement en france
le quasiment dans le monde entier
qu'est ce que ça vous fait je crois que
je fais effectivement c'est ce qui rend
cette crise est difficile à analyser à
comprendre
je crois que beaucoup de gens essaient
de se référer soit des cracks passé de
929 ou encore 2008 soit des situations
de guerre et je crois que ses précédents
en fait manquent leur cible
parce que ce que nous vivons est
vraiment sans précédent notamment avec
le fait qu'on a la moitié de l'humanité
aujourd'hui qui se trouve confiné
d'abord le confinement était inconnu
depuis le 17e siècle la dernière fois
c'est peut-être à milan en europe
au xviie siècle et puis ensuite on monte
donc la nature absolument singulière de
cet événement pour moi il ya trois 3
chose qui distingue cette crise des
précédentes
d'abord son caractère universel ce
confinement de plusieurs milliards
d'hommes la deuxième chose c'est qu'on a
trois crises en fait qui s'enchevêtrent
une crise sanitaire
une tuile économique et puis une crise
financière donc d'une certaine manière
on a le mélange de la grippe espagnole
de 1918 qui a fait 50 millions de morts
du krach de 1929
et puis
de l'effondrement du crédit de 2008 mais
on a fait trois éléments qui se
combinent et la dernière chose c'est que
on a une réaction très forte de la
politique économique
en quelques semaines on a engagé plus de
7 milliards de dollars de mesures soient
des gouvernements soient des banques
centrales pour soutenir l'économie et
par ailleurs ouvrir des lignes de crédit
pour sauver les entreprises et
contrastant avec cette mobilisation de
la politique économique on a une
politique sanitaire qui d'abord et se
déroule nation par nation qui est
extrêmement différentes éclatées et avec
des performances qui sont aussi
extrêmement divers tu pour l'instant
force est de constater que les pays qui
ont le mieux géré la crise ce sont les
démocraties daddy se sont taiwan la
corée du sud qui ont réussi à la fois à
éviter le confinement et à limiter très
fortement la propagation de l'épidémie
et le nombre des victimes
et ce avec un très bon pilotage de la
crise
avec également la complexion généralisé
de la population
un dépistage systématique avec le
recours aux technologies et puis avec un
appel au civisme et en import control
est une réaffirmation des valeurs
collectives de la population la france
dans tout ça commente comment jugez-vous
la façon dont nous gérons cette crise
mais à la lumière de ce qui s'est passé
en dans ces démocraties laïques
il est vrai que sur le plan sanitaire
je pense que la france a largement
échoué à gérer cette crise
au départ et a eu clairement à défaut de
d'anticipation un défaut de coordination
ministériel et puis je pense que la
question la pénurie de masques et de
test de dépistage leur importance a été
sous-estimée et enfin sur le plan des
nouvelles technologies et du cyclisme en
matière de nouvelles technologies
on a eu la preuve la démonstration du
retard français et en matière de civisme
il est clair que nous payons là des
cohésions désintégration du tissu social
et de la communauté des citoyens sur
plan sanitaire comme sur le risque sur
le plan économique en revanche je pense
que pour l'instant la crise est plutôt
bien géré et donc à cause de ses
problèmes de ses failles
on a dû recourir à confinement qui est
très pénalisant pour l'économie puisque
la production a chuté d'à peu près 30 5%
et que chaque chaque mois de confinement
coûte deux à trois points de pipe
en revanche sur le plan de la
réassurance je pense qu'il ya une vraie
mobilisation du budget une vraie
préoccupation de faire survivre les
entreprises qui est fondamental parce
que c'est par la survie des entreprises
qu'on peut garantir la croissance
potentielle les emplois et donc les
recettes fiscales de l'avenir
et puis la bce après une erreur de
communication initiale s'est bien
rattrapé à met à disposition de
l'économie européenne fait 156 yards y
une faille importante qui est celle de
la solidarité entre les pays européens
qui une nouvelle fois n'a pas réussi à
vraiment se matérialiser nous avons
abandonné
l'italie lève lui est venue de chine de
russie de cuba ce qui est pour le moins
paradoxal et autant sur le plan médical
on a une coopération qui se passe bien
comme on le voit dans l'est avec le
luxembourg l'allemagne ou également la
suisse autant sur le plan des états
membres européens
cette crise sanitaire est gérée
essentiellement pays par pays et on n'a
pas de fort pilotage de la crise par
bruxelles et la commission justement les
ennemis de rock aujourd'hui de l'union
européenne
insiste sur ses défaillances au niveau
des yeux et sur fond il s'est passé ce
qui se passe très souvent des rues des
replis nationaux oui c'est ce qu'on doit
constater c'est à dire que à la décharge
de l'union européenne il faut bien
rappeler que l'union le l'origine le
marché commun donc cette union a été
créé par le droit et par le marché
pour contourner l'échec de la communauté
européenne de défense est donc pour
contourner les problèmes politiques et
stratégiques
il se trouve que dans ce monde du 21e
siècle c'est un nombre de chocs un monde
de de crise économique
un monde de péril géopolitique un monde
de risques globaux climatiques
sanitaires ou terroristes et donc il est
certain que l'europe doit se réinventer
se réorienter vers la sécurité et la
stratégie alors qu'elle n'a pas été fait
pour file vers la politique
est ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui c'est
que la réponse technique est plutôt
bonne
par la banque centrale européenne et à
linverse la réponse politique elle est
défaillante et la chine
la chine est elle pas en train de
devenir le modèle la chine a une
position extrêmement ambiguë puisqu'il
faut bien rappeler que c'est à cause du
total capitalisme chinois et de ce mot
pas citer que cette crise a pris
l'ampleur qu'elle a aujourd'hui puisque
pendant deux mois les autorités
chinoises ont occulté l'épidémie et ont
influencé le ms pour qu'elle ne
n'assistent pas qu elle ne déclare pas
le risque de pandémie
les autorités chinoises ont clairement
aussi occulter le nombre de moments
leydier est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la chine
est dans la situation paradoxale d'être
la première à sortir de crise de
bénéficier d'un confinement qui a été à
la fois très dur et très très précoce et
de pouvoir du coup installer un système
de propagande pour prétendre que l adieu
gérer cette crise que les autres états
et notamment les notamment les
démocraties au moment même où le choc
arrive en europe qui est aujourd'hui
l'épicentre et où le choc va arriver
demain aux états unis ils vont beaucoup
souffrir pourquoi parce que les états
unis sont vulnérables notamment du fait
des failles de leur système de santé qui
leur coûtent 17 % du pipe mais qui
laissent 30 millions de personnes sont
rassurantes mais sans assurance santé
donc en fait cette crise cette crise va
s'ajouter aux autres pour rajouter à la
tension internationale et à l'opposition
entre les deux modèles
la chine va va le mettre à profit pour
vanter son modèle autoritaire elle pour
essayer de mettre à profit le nouveau
trou d'air des démocrates et les anelka
alors on voit bien que donald trump
rechignent à appliquer le confirme henry
sait les conséquences économiques que
cela peut avoir
comment le le trouvez vous écouter aux
états unis si on prend les trois grandes
crises qui s'enchevêtrent la crise
sanitaire va être très dur parce que
comme je le rappelais le système de
santé américain comporte des failles
importantes parce qu'une partie
importante de la population n'est pas
couverte pratiquement 9 % et parce que
le l'assurance-santé disparaît assez
vite quand les gens sont au chômage
on ya eu 3 3 millions d'inscriptions au
chômage en une semaine
la semaine dernière aux états unis donc
et par ailleurs la politique de donald
trump a été une nouvelle fois
complètement erratiques
il a commencé par le déni de la crise
ensuite il a fermé les frontières ce
qu'il affectionne toujours
ensuite ils sont les remis à l'accueil
qu'il est il avait expliqué qu'il allait
arbitrer en faveur de l'économie et au
détriment de la santé
ce petit clairement n'est pas n'est pas
tenable
le dernier élément sur le sanitaire il
faut toujours se rappeler que la santé
n'est pas une des compétences de l'état
fédéral
donc les états américains ont chacun
leur stratégie aujourd'hui on a une
vingtaine d'états qui ont recours au
confinement et qui représente à peu près
la moitié de la population américaine
à l'inversé encore sur le plan
économique et financier la réaction des
états unis a été très forte
le congrès et la maison blanche se sont
mis d'accord sur un plan soutien de 2200
milliards de dollars c'est 10% du pile
des états unis et la feb a généralisé
les lignes de crédit dont seulement aux
banques mais aussi aux entreprises en
décidant dé rachat de d'actions
d'obligations sur le marché primaire et
son marché secondaire
donc la réaction économique et
financière est plutôt bonne en revanche
on a une énorme faille sur la santé du
canada
à l'image de tomlin vous dit que
l'occident boîte utiliser ces armes qui
sont là la raison et la liberté
mais sur le plan sanitaire ça se
traduirait comment si vous voulez sur le
plan raison et liberté je crois que ça
pointe bien on fuit les
dysfonctionnements des démocraties dans
l'est dans les derniers temps d'abord
cette crise est incontestablement l'une
des lunes des victimes collatérales
première de cette crise se laver risque
bien d'être la liberté politique ont
levé aujourd'hui avec les atteintes très
forte qui sont portées aux libertés
publiques par le confinement mais aussi
par le recours à des méthodes très
intrusive de contrôle de la population
et on risque de le voir demain avec la
montée d'un désir de sécurité tels que
en plus de la revendication d'égalité en
plus pour certains de l'état d'urgence
climatique
cela risque d'être en prétexte ce besoin
de sécurité y compris sanitaire ce
besoin de protection sociale pour
remettre en cause la liberté et la
démocratie
quant à la raison il est vrai que la
raison a beaucoup souffert dans les
dernières années elle a été notamment le
la science qui a été mise au rang des
accusés par donald trump l'elysée par le
seuil qu'on pense par exemple aux
polémique en france sur les vaccins qui
paraissent aujourd'hui bien dérisoire
alors que tout le monde aujourd'hui
cherchent à mettre au point un vaccin
contre le corona le virus donc cette
crise
elle peut comme toute crise est retourné
à la tragédie ou être un facteur de
chance elle peut accélérer la
décomposition des libertés publiques la
poussée populiste et donnait l'avantagé
aux démocrates eurent au plan
international contre les démocraties où
venant après quand même une série
terrible de choc d'avertissement le 11
septembre les guerres perdues en
afghanistan en irak et en syrie
venant après le krach de 2008 qui a
montré une gestion complètement
irresponsable du capitalisme
venant après la crise de l'euro venant
après les les vagues migratoires
ce peut être un réveil pour les
démocraties occidentales et finalement
l'occasion pour elle de réaliser que
maintenant il faut vraiment qu'elle
serait avant tout qu'elle essaie de
travailler un nouveau pacte économique
et social qu'elle réponde le capitalisme
qu'elle renforce qu'elle réinvente une
communauté en des citoyens avec des
valeurs collectives plus forte et
qu'elle renoue justement avec la raison
et avec la liberté
sur le plan économique que vous
préconisez quoi sur le plan économique
aujourd'hui on a une certitude peu
radical donc sur le plan économique il
ya le court terme et long terme de le
court terme ce qui est décisif c'est de
ne pas casser les entreprises parce
qu'elles sont les garantes de la
croissance potentielle des emplois et
des ressources fiscales du futur ensuite
la la relance pas dépendre de manière
prioritaire de la politique sanitaire
parce que on ne peut avoir de vraie
relance que si les gens peuvent
retourner au travail dans des conditions
de sécurité acceptables
donc c'est aujourd'hui pour ça les deux
priorités de court terme sortir du
confinement avec notamment des garanties
en terme de distribution de masques de
dépistage et de mise à niveau des
capacités hospitalières et par ailleurs
permettre aux entreprises de reprendre
le cours de leur activité sur le moyen
terme vont se poser des questions très
très importante
d'abord il va falloir vivre
c'est la deuxième fois en un peu plus de
dix ans que les grands pays développés
auront dû mobiliser va à 40 % de leur
pib sous forme de dette publique
pourrait assurer un grand choc
c'était un krach financier en 2008 c'est
aujourd'hui une crise sanitaire
nous allons tous vivre avec des dettes
publiques à la japonaise qu'ils vont
représenter
entre 150 et 200 pour cent du pid et
personne ne sait combien de temps ce
château de cartes financier pourra tenir
ensuite cette expérience du confinement
va montre et leur part face aux
démocraties asiatiques montrent qu'il
faut massivement investir sur les
nouvelles technologies sur les
infrastructures mais aussi sur la
formation
évidemment delà de la population et puis
la dernière grande inconnue
ce sont les choses qui peuvent arriver
nous pouvons avoir de nouveaux chocs qui
met l'économie à l'arrêt ou qui impose
aux gens de rester chez eux
un choc par exemple une frappe
cybernétique généralisée que créer un
arrêt complet de l'économie c'est ce
qu'on a vécu sur l'estonie il y a
quelques années et par ailleurs
aujourd'hui le réchauffement climatique
pourrait aussi contraindre les gens à
rester chez eux soit une partie
importante du une partie importante du
temps donc je crois que il faudra tirer
les leçons cette crise aussi pour
anticiper cette fois-ci et nouveau choc
qui pourrait arriver et pour renforcer
la résilience de nos nations
donc leur capacité à assurer la
continuité de la vie nationale en toutes
circonstances nicolas baverez 16 sur le
plan technologique
on voit bien comme en asie on s'est
servi des deux technologies de pointe et
même de l'intelligence artificielle pour
combattre l'épidémie
il ne semble pas que ce soit le cas pour
l'instant d'en france dans l'europe
qu'en pensez vous tiens je pense que le
ya deux questions qui se posent d'abord
premièrement aujourd'hui en europe la
situation est différente par exemple en
israël mais en europe nous n'avons pas
la capacité technique de mettre en
oeuvre ce qui a été fait
en corée du sud à taiwan ou à hong kong
ou encore à singapour
donc il ya un premier une première
question c'est la nuisent à niveau des
infrastructures et de l'équipement de
l'équipement technique
la deuxième question qui se pose c'est
la question des libertés publiques
et là je crois que nous devons y
réfléchir avec l'arbitrage doit bouger
il ne s'agit pas de sacrifier la liberté
comme je les dis elle va subir beaucoup
d' attaque et il est essentiel de la
préserver mehal inverse
il est certain que il y a des choses sur
lequel il faut accepter de bouger par
exemple en matière de suivi par
téléphone il est très important que
quand on a une personne malade qui a
rencontré beaucoup d'autres il est
normal qu'on puisse utiliser son
téléphone pour prévenir le risque de
santé publique sur les personnes qu'elle
a rencontrées
ça me paraît totalement légitime il ne
s'agit pas de mettre en place le big
brother chinois numérique qui permet de
suivre en permanence la population est
de mettre en place un système de crédit
social
mais à l inverse je pense que toi un
intérêt général comme la santé publique
pour une maladie qui se révèle pouvoir
être mortelle et pas seulement pour les
personnes âgées comme on l'a trop
souvent dit mais en fait que pour
l'ensemble de la population dans ces cas
là il faut pouvoir utiliser les
technologies et pour l'instant nous
n'avons pas les moyens
c'est pour ça que c'est une des failles
qu'il nous faudra absolument combler
avec donc un nouvel équilibre en termes
qui assure la sécurité mais évidemment
sans sacrifier la vie vers sa part est
toujours difficile des comparses de
sécurité en général c'est pour fst les
libertés vous savez bien dans l'histoire
c'est toujours été comme ça oui mais si
ce que vous voyez l'exemple pratique que
je vous accueille
il ya comme je vous l'indiquais nous
savons tous que à la suite de cette
crise qui touche tout le monde dans sa
vie quotidienne personnel avec un
traumatisme ce traumatisme inouïe du
confinement derrière nous allons avoir
un énorme besoin de sécurité et nous
savons que ce besoin de sécurité va
s'exercer et va vouloir remettre en
cause de la liberté
je pense qu'on peut tenir la balance et
que par exemple exemple que je donnais
pour prévenir la propagation de la
maladie là on a un vrai intérêt public
et par ailleurs il faut souligner que
par exemple sur les études
épidémiologiques
il ya toute une partie de la recherche
qui peut s'effectuer aussi sur une base
anonyme et ça évidemment il faut le il
faut le faire donc c'est pour ça que si
on réfléchit un peu on peut trouver au
el madhali dé manière de concilier
liberté et sécurité
mais il est vrai que le point
d'équilibré va devoir changer et que la
braise dans le domaine de la santé nous
manques sont assez criant aujourd'hui
dans un pays comme la france
alors est ce que c'est le résultat de la
réduction des budgets publics ou comme
vous auriez peut-être tendance à penser
de la gratuité générale on déçoit
je crois que les les deux sont un peu
lié et c'est à dire que à partir du
moment où le la santé publique a été
pilotée par la gratuité on a forcément
la mise en place d'un système de
rationnement et un ajustement par la
baisse de la qualité des soins et il a
encore je pense qu'on n'a pas
suffisamment réfléchi ce qu'on voit aux
états unis c'est à dire le fait qu' il
est très important qu'ils aient une
couverture universelle de la population
et ça c'est important
évidemment pour les individus mais aussi
pour la santé publique
al'inverse l'idée que tout soit gratuit
pour tout le monde et pour tous les
soins
ça c'est une idée qui n'a aucun sens au
plan de la temple et qui n'a aucun sens
sur le plan de la solidarité qui n'a
aucun sens sur le plan économique
et c'est vrai que c'est politique de
rationnement ont entraîné une baisse de
la qualité une baisse de la qualité des
soins et une organisation des soins sur
le mode de la pénurie
c'est aussi ce qui explique par exemple
cette aberration qui a été la
suppression des stocks stratégiques des
masques puisqu'en 2012 on va aller
encore plus d'un milliard de masques en
stock et que ce stock a été réduit à 145
millions au début de la crise ce qui
explique que très rapidement on se soit
retrouvé dans
tuation de pénurie criante et que parce
qu'on n'avait pas de mac
on a prétendu qu'il n'était pas utile ce
qui est évidemment et malheureusement à
masquer faute alors sur le corps
politique maintenant j'en viens à
deauville qui voudrait consacrer un
livre il est reproché à la france sa
centralisation son inflation législative
des lois inefficaces et inappliquée
qu'on remplace par des lois plus
contraignantes encore mais pas plus
appliqué il résumé de la façon suivante
une règles rigides et une pratique molle
ils reprochaient également les emplois
réservés les traits brand décidé pur
l'égoïsme de classe de la classe
dominante en particulier l'immobilité
sociales et politiques
alors là aussi sur le plan politique
qu'est ce que cette crise du corps 9e us
nous apprend je crois que la france le
camp navires us et pour la france comme
pour tous les pays développés un test
impitoyable pour les institutions et
pour les dirigeants
donc c'est une crise majeure on va voir
sans doute malheureusement aux états
unis que le système américain aura réagi
encore plus sans doute de manière plus
inefficace et dangereuse que la plupart
des pays d'europe
pour la france on retrouve le point de
croisement entre donc cette crise sans
précédent même si d'ailleurs tocqueville
a connu les épidémies de choléra de 1832
c'est pour cette raison qu'il est
revenue les états unis parce qu'il était
inquiet pour sa famille et est donc on
retrouve là cette parenthèse une crise
générale mais un certain nombre de
traverses français que tocqueville avait
pointé pour expliquer les cours
particulièrement portée de notre
histoire
il ya d'abord une très grande
centralisation le fait que la nation
s'est créé autour de l'état il y a donc
également un très grand individualiste
un très grand individualisme et puis
hier c'est la faiblesse de la société
civile entre les deux puits
que l'état qu'il soit monarchique ou
révolutionnaire a toujours poursuivi et
cherchait à obtenir la suppression des
corps intermédiaires
aujourd'hui il est vrai que les pays qui
gère le mieux cette crise souvent sont
des pays qui ont su s'appuyer aussi sur
la mobilisation de la population par
alain initiative évidemment des états
mais avec des forts système de
solidarité donc on retrouve comme
toujours à la fois les traits d'une
grande crise qui dépasse la france comme
les guerres du xxème siècle où les
grandes crises économiques dépassent
notre pays et en même temps un certain
nombre de pathologies française qu'il
contribue à expliquer votre manque de
réactivité
de ce point de vue là qui est vrai que
l' extrême centralisation du pouvoir
étant est une difficulté
je veux d'ailleurs à ce propos qu on a
du coup à l'occasion de cette crise a
créé un nouveau régime de circonstances
exceptionnelles avec la loi d'urgence
sanitaire qui prévoit des pouvoirs
notamment des pouvoirs de réquisition
confié au milieu de la santé sans aucun
contrôle et qui sont à la fois
exorbitantes du droit commun est très
préoccupant du produit des libertés
ainsi que la vraie je rappelle que vous
pouvez publier l'alertent démocratique
aux éditions l'observatoire et le monde
selon quelle ville chez tallandier
portez vous bien on va faire une pause
et on se retrouve juste après avec
julien duquenne
[Musique]
bonjour julien duquenne vous êtes
journalistes que vous avez créé à
l'écart admis la collection carnets d'
alerte aux presses du châtelet vous avez
publié notamment les excès de la finance
c'était en 2017 les semences un
patrimoine vital en voie de disparition
et plus récemment puisqu'il avait été
publié en novembre dernier vivre mieux
sans croissance
alors la mise au ralenti ou à l'arrêt
pur et simple
une bonne partie de l'économie mondiale
doit vous sembler divine surprise
une divine surprise le sait pas parce
que je pense qu'il ya rien de pire
qu'une société centrée sur la croissance
qui n'a pas de croissance ou dans leur
enquête que j'ai réalisé où j'ai
interrogé justement énormément de
chercheurs de spécialistes d'acteurs de
la société civile
ils disent tous qu'il faut organiser la
décroissance est pas subir la récession
ce qui risque de nous arriver là l'insee
a publié note en fin de semaine c'est
d'ici à un mois de confinement on risque
d'avoir une baisse du pib de l'ordre de
3% au niveau de l'année en france donc
ça va être une récession mais subir une
récession ce n'est pas la peine c'est
pas la même chose que d'organiser une
décroissance qui serait un nouveau
modèle parce que là depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale on a un modèle
qui est totalement basée sur la
croissance une fois dans l'ouvragé
après avoir réalisé cette enquête on se
rend bien compte qu'il faudrait qu on
déconstruit ce modèle est qu'on se
construisent un autre modèle là le
risque c'est qu'on ait une décroissance
une récession avec moins de consommation
où on voit bien qu'il ya l'activité la
lune c10 a diminué de l'ordre de 35%
avec une augmentation pour tout ce qui
est alimentaire mais en moyenne une
baisse de l'ordre de 35%
mais le risque si c'est pour avoir des
chômage ou du chômage une augmentation
des inégalités c'est pas en tout cas le
modèle où le voilà le modèle qui paraît
intéressant il faudrait organiser cette
décroissance plutôt que de subir la
récession
néanmoins la croissance va baisser on va
mal connaître
et c'est chiant est à peu près certain
vous pensez que ça peut être bénéfique
aux 106 finalement ça nous prépare ça
nous oblige à réfléchir justement à
organiser ce nouveau modèle que vous
préconisez bas je l'espère je sais pas
si ça va ça va fonctionner mais je
l'espère en tout cas cette cette crise
elle est révélatrice d'énormément de
dysfonctionnements que nous avons dans
notre société comme vous dis-je avec un
livre aussi sur les excès de la finance
où j'ai pas mal aussi travailler sur
tout ce qui l est et les questions
agricoles
on voit que ça de crise elle regroupe
tout ça il ya des chercheurs qui ont
montré des chercheurs comme serge morand
ou jean françois guégan le lien entre la
baisse de la biodiversité et
l'augmentation du nombre d'épidémie que
ç'a un impact que la baisse de
biodiversité a un impact sur le
l'augmentation du nombre des d'épidémie
donc c'est aussi une crise écologique
que nous avons alors on pourrait se dire
qu'il ya eu énormément d'épidémie dans
auparavant qui a toujours eu d'épidémie
des épidémies il ya moins de gens qui
sont infectés par des épidémies mais le
nombre de d'épidémie a augmenté depuis
1940 de l'ordre s'étaient multipliées
par 10 d'après les chiffres de serge
mourant donc on voit que le nom
d'épidémie augmentent
à cause notamment de cette baisse de
biodiversité les animaux sauvages en
moins de places pourra pour vivre se
déplace dans des zones où alors même il
ya de la baisse de biodiversité au sein
des animaux sauvages par exemple les
prédateurs comme les lynx ou les hyènes
sont moins nombreux ces prédateurs
premier les plus importants il ya moins
du coup il y a plus de rongeurs qui vont
être véhicules de pathogènes et aussi
cette déforestation qui est parfois due
notamment à une agriculture intensive
pas toujours mais qui peut être dû à ça
par exemple pour faire des palmiers à
huile on va déforester et et tout ça
peut avoir un impact sur après
l'augmentation du nombre d'épidémie je
vous donne juste un exemple j'ai pas
faire trop long sur ce point là mais
c'est pour montrer que c'est une
problématique globale
ces chercheurs vont parler par exemple
du virus nipah qui qui est apparu dans
la fin des années 90 en indonésie et
c'est parce que les chauves souris
avaient moins de place dans les forêts
qui à cause justement de la production
de palmier à huile et se sont déplacés
dans des fermes elles ont contaminé des
cochons qui en plus après qui ont
contaminé des des êtres humains il ya eu
toute une chaîne qui s'est mis en place
aujourd'hui on connaît pas la cause
complète c'est peut-être un pangolin une
chauve souris mais de toute façon et
nous les chercheurs expliquent ça on
pourrait mettre des années à comprendre
vraiment la chaîne de transmission et
eux ils disent que depuis vingt ans ils
ont déjà prouvé qu'il ya une
augmentation du nombre des épidémies à
cause de la baisse de la biodiversité et
que c'est pas forcément c'est pas lié
qu'à des pratiques qui sont en chine en
fait réservé à des pratiques
c'est vraiment alliée à une baisse de la
biodiversité au niveau mondial et là on
voit qu'il ya tous tout s'emboîte parce
que l'augmentation je vais essayer
d'être l'air mais l'augmentation le fait
qu'on a un système qui est basé sur la
croissance c'est aussi ça commence
toujours au moment où on vide les les
champs des paysans pour qu'ils aillent
dans les villes ou nourrir les
bidonvilles dans les pays en voie de
développement donc la base à chaque fois
on voit que l'agriculture à une base
très importante
à partir du moment où on a un modèle qui
va être basé sur le pib sur
l'augmentation du pib
on va passer à une agriculture
industrielle qui va réduire le nombre de
personnes qui vont être dans les champs
et on va partir à ce modèle là donc il
faudrait qu'on change notre modèle de
façon plus globale et la chaîne
alimentaire l'agriculture a toujours un
rôle très central on le voit dans cette
crise de la biodiversité avec les
actuels mais aussi pour avoir un modèle
qui va être respectueux de
l'environnement j'espère j'ai pas été
trop vite sur ce point là mais c'était
ça me paraissait important de de relier
les deux parce que tout est lié en fait
la crise que nous avons actuelle c'est
pas qu'une crise sanitaire c'est une
crise aussi écologique une crise
sanitaire une crise écologique
économique et donc c'est une crise
globale en fait l'idée du kent la
productivité de l'agriculture a très
très peu
évolué entre le moyen-age et la guerre
de 14 il fallait à peu près le même
nombre d'hommes dans les champs pour
récolter un hectare de pommes de terre
enfin nous la pomme de terre c'est
arrivé un peu plus tard un hectare dans
quoi que ce soit on va dire ce qui a été
augmenté la productivité évidemment
c'est la technique c'est la technologie
et c'est la nécessité démographique de
nourrir le plus grand nombre de gens
possible
il a fallu à un moment 60 % de la
population active dans l'agriculture
pour trame nourrira pays comme la france
aujourd'hui on pourrait dire qu'il faut
30 4% de la population active
quand on nourrir beaucoup plus que la
france c'est la chip vous voulez revenir
ben oui c'était en fait on pourrait tout
à fait il ya plusieurs études qui
montrent qu'on pourrait tout à fait
nourrir la planète même avec
l'augmentation de la population
on pourrait tout à fait d'ouvrir la
planète avec l'agroécologie
l'agroécologie ce n'est pas avec le
tueur traditionnel c'est d'autre quand
même ça peut être lié mais c'est
d'autres modèles agricoles c'est souvent
très techniques
on peut avoir la culture associée un peu
d'élevage pour avoir du bon fumier pour
faire du bon compost c'est c'est pas
revenir à l'agricultural l'agriculture
traditionnelle c'est même souvent plus
technique que l'agriculture
conventionnelle et il ya plusieurs
études qui montrent qu'on peut tout à
fait nourrir la planète avec la low
écologie dans les pays en voie de
développement ça augmente même les
rendements à 2 lors de 79 % dans
certains ces endroits parce que les
agriculteurs dans les pays en afrique
par exemple ne peuvent pas acheter de
semences améliorées et des pesticides et
en plus ça marche moins bien danser dans
ces pays là donc c'est vrai que souvent
on dit oui mais il faut bien nourrir la
planète mais en fait c'est aujourd'hui
c'est d'ailleurs pas l'agriculture
industrielle qui nourrit en grande
majorité la planète dans nos pays à vous
à nous oui mais dans tous les autres
pays c'est souvent l'agriculture
familiale ayant et dans certaines zones
notamment en afrique la faim dans le
monde a tendance à augmenter parce que
justement on a amené ces agriculteurs à
se détourner de ski de la la production
vivrière pour aller vers une agriculture
exportatrice par exemple au burkina faso
il ya beaucoup de encore de sous
alimentation il ya 10% des terres qui
sont pour consacrer à l'exportation de
coton
donc en fait c'est vrai qu'il ya tout un
modèle à revoir mêmes
nos idées reçues en fait ce n'est pas
l'agriculture industrielle qui nous et
la planète ça pourrait réduire une
partie des rendements dans nos pays à
nos mais nous on a 30 % de gaspillage
alimentaire donc on pourrait largement
nourrir la france en passant totalement
en agriculture biologique ou en
agroécologie mais pour l'instant on
accepte environ 7% des terres qui sont
qui sont en agriculture biologique
on a en agriculture biologique pour le
coup certifiés néanmoins alors revenons
à ce coup d'arrêt convient de donner à
l'économie mondiale aux échanges aux
transports j'imagine qu'elle n'est pas
très fier que les avions ne décollent ni
que les les voitures redémarrent
ça semble quand même une répétition
générale
ça n'est pas volontaire évidemment
néanmoins si on écoutait vos
préconisations à vous aux décroissants
en général kir a mis ça ressemblerait un
peu à cela nous annonce safran semblait
pas à ça parce que là on est enfermés
chez nous y'a aucune crédibilité on est
beaucoup mieux nos ordinateurs
là on est on est beaucoup considèrent
dans les villes du coup on est en plus
en écho très connecté le numérique et
aimer nos énormément de gaz à effet de
serre c'est très polluants de fond que
je sais ça se fait pas du tout ce monde
là ça sera un monde totalement différent
qui est d'ailleurs à inventer en fait
c'est un monde qui a inventé et je pense
qu'il serait pas similaires partout dans
le monde
ça serait justement on a tendance à
vouloir préconisé le même modèle partout
dans le monde mais là ça serait un
modèle qui serait plus basé sur les
territoires qui serait à inventer la
société civile a inventé déjà énormément
de deux façons de vivre autrement
reste aujourd'hui elle passer à plus
grande échelle a organisé cette sobriété
ou à organiser cette décroissance à plus
grande échelle
mais on a de la chance la société civile
à expérimenter partout dans le monde des
solutions pour réussir à vivre autrement
il ya des choses comme je disais tout à
l'heure il ya énormément de chercheurs
aussi qu'ils ont mis en place qui ont
montré qu'on pouvait se passer de
croissance mais créer des emplois dès et
des chercheurs comme jean gadrey
dominique méda serge latouche paul ariès
il y en a beaucoup qui ont montré qu'on
pouvait avoir avoir une société qui
n'est pas basé sur la croissance et par
exemple créé des emplois pour revenir au
modèle agricole
si on passait en agriculture biologique
en france sont les 30%
d'emplois supplémentaires certes ça se
fait pas le même qu'aujourd'hui mais il
y aurait quand même 30 % des emplois
supplémentaires sans avoir une
augmentation des quantités
donc si on n'est pas toujours à l'arche
à la recherche de gains de productivité
on peut avoir des créations d'emplois
sans forcément avoir de la croissance
mais s'est on en a besoin on a toujours
eu de la croissance mais on rêve de la
croissance que depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale et c'est à
partir du moment où on a eu de la
croissance qu'on a toutes les formes de
pollution qui ont aussi décollé c'est
flagrant quand on voit les graphiques on
voit que le pib commencé à augmenter et
pendant un temps toutes les formes de
pollution augmente la quasi-totalité des
cours d'eau et des nappes phréatiques en
france on polluée par les pesticides et
les nitrates lesquels les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre ont décollé 75% des
variétés de semences ont disparu en un
siècle on a toujours eu l'impression que
l'homme a craint la fin du monde ou la
fin de l'humanité mais on nage qu'on
voit les courbes c'est à partir de 1945
où tout se dégrade
on a réussi à lui mettre du plastique
partout dans l'océan enfin en 50 ans
donc en fait on a l'impression que que
l'homme a toujours craint cette fin du
monde toujours eu cette crainte que on
abîme la nature mais en fait on le fait
que assez peu de temps en fait ce de
façon aussi massive en tout cas c'est
assez récent et on voit bien cette
corrélation entre ça existait avant mais
en tout cas là ça s'est accéléré après
la seconde guerre mondiale et on voit
bien cette corrélation entre à partir du
moment où on a eu un set cette
croissance qui a été on a voulu de cette
croissance infinie limité on a utilisé
de plus en plus de ressources
cette planète et c'est pas et est en
plus aujourd'hui on a du mal à avoir
cette croissance là on risque d'avoir
une récession mais on a même du mal à
voir cette croissance de toute façon
donc d'avoir un modèle qui est basé sur
la croissance sans en avoir autant le
définir autrement
certes on ne saura peut-être une société
moins mobiles certainement plus convient
pas j'espère plus convivial et pas du
tout car pour la actuellement mais qui
serait complètement différente plus
centré sur les territoires avec des
villes certainement moins grande et là
on voit bien aussi le rôle des
métropoles dans le fait que l'épidémie
se propage plus rapidement donc
certainement avec des villes moins
grande pour avoir des territoires qui
sont aussi autonome alimentairement et
pas avoir
on voit bien qu'il faut avoir des
chaînes alimentaires totalement
différentes et pas seulement le façon de
cultiver mais aussi la façon de vendre
tous enfin revoir toute la chaîne
alimentaire dans ce nouveau modèle il
faudrait inventer vraiment mais inventer
en même temps en temps je d inventer et
c'est déjà dans la société civile depuis
depuis déjà des décennies il ya plein de
gens qui font différemment aujourd'hui
ne s'est pas encore remis à plus grande
échelle
j'étais effectivement moins mobile vous
l'avez dit là mais dans la répétition
générale générale la plupart des des
avions sont cloués au sol
les voitures en tout cas pour une bonne
partie d'entre elles restent au garage
cha encore une fois il me semble c'est
une embellie général
oui il ya une sorte de récompense quand
vous posez cette question oui il ya une
sorte de répétition générale où ça mais
toutes à l'arrêt en fait une partie des
usines des magasins fermés on peut pas
aller acheter on consomme trois fois de
plus qu'il ya qui lie à 60 ans on a bien
vu que les français quand les magasins
ont tous fermé les consommateurs que
nous sommes
il y en a certains en tout cas qui se
sont précipités pour acheter alors y
avait la peur de la pénurie alimentaire
mais il y avait peut-être aussi ce
besoin d'acheter on voit que le commerce
en ligne en ce moment yann ça ça a
fonctionné enfin il ya eu cette peur de
ne pas pouvoir acheter donc oui ça nous
ça nous limite dans nos achats ça nous
je pense que en tout cas j'espère que ça
serait l'occasion pour essayer de
repartir sur un autre en modèle par la
suite et de l'organiser au niveau
étatique et pas leur gagné et le mettre
en place et par repartir sur le même
système
on a bien vu après la crise des
subprimes on a mis énormément d'argent
4500 milliards d'euros a été accordée
par la commission européenne par les
états pourraient déverser vers les
institutions les établissements
financiers et très peu est revenu vers
l'économie réelle
donc il faudrait pas qu'on fasse cette
répétition la la il faudrait mettre en
place à on est bien beaucoup de gens là
en ce moment il ya des tribunes peu
beaucoup beaucoup de gens de la société
civile qui le réclame de mettre en place
un plan vous pourrez dire un espèce de
plan marshall de la transition
écologique ou pour aider au début l'état
aurait besoin d'un investissement alors
pour ces investissements de départ pour
organiser et mettre en place un autre
système où on consommerait moins
de bien et on construit consommerait
moins d'énergie parce que on ne sait pas
croître sans consommer de l'énergie et
sans polluer la planète on a pensé un
moment il ya eu on va pouvoir le faire
enfin sans que les aînés en passant avec
les énergies renouvelables doit de les
experts que j'ai interrogés on n'a aucun
parmi les 60 qui m'ont dit qu'il fallait
pas passer aux énergies renouvelables
mais tous disent attention s'il n'y a
pas une part de sobriété ça sert à rien
on va utiliser des métaux et on va on va
polluer et aura plus assez de métaux il
risque d'avoir des débuts des des
manques de métaux dans les années à
venir donc c'est on voit bien que à
chaque fois on essaye de chercher une
solution à un problème est que si on
change pas les fondements on n'y
arrivera pas pour revenir à la crise des
subprimes
on a mis des des réformes après cette
crise des subprimes mais à chaque fois
on a complexifié 100 ch a changé la
structure même des marchés financiers et
à chaque fois on fait la même chose on
change pas la structure
on a mis direct très complexe à un petit
peu augmenté le le capital des banques 2
à 3 fois mais on n'a pas changé le le
problème profond des marchés financiers
le fait qu'on peut pas laisser une
banques faire faillite parce que nos
dépôts restent des garanties à vos
activités spéculatives et que ça peut
entraîner toute l'économie donc on n'a
pas changé les fondements le secteur
bancaire est toujours aussi important
que dans les années qu'en 2008 on n'a
pas changé les fondements de notre
système
vous avez raison on a tout fait pour que
tout recommence comme maintenant mais ne
croyez vous pas que les gens qui sont
aujourd'hui confinée dans l'eure à leur
domicile n'espère pas que tout va
recommencer justement comme avant est ce
que pour atteindre la sobriété donc vous
parler dont parle également pierre rabhi
et qui effectivement est indispensable à
une véritable transition écologique pas
la transition'' évidence un joli la
vraie transition écologique qui ne
faudrait pas toucher un peu moins une
dictature
est-ce que sans dictature vous pensez
que vous allez y arriver alors moi là
c'est peut-être la partie dans mon
enquête la plus subjective c'est la
dernière partie de l'anc est un peu plus
subjectif cette partie là parce que j'en
sais rien tu vas tout à fait franche
après j'ai interrogé pas mal de
politologues et pas mal d'acteurs de la
société civile et les politologues
disent justement
il faut avoir plus de démocratie directe
plus de pour pourvoir que les gens
comprennent c'est ces mesures et qu' on
puisse réussir à les mettre en place
pour avoir une compréhension vraiment
des sujets pour réussir à mettre en
place les mesures de sobriété sinon
elles seraient pas acceptées c'est
toujours la crainte ça craint d'avoir
une dictature verte
en même temps c'est vrai que dans
l'histoire il ya jamais eu dictature qui
était respectueuse de l'environnement
donc on peut se dire qu'il faut
justement avoir plus de démocratie plus
de démocratie directe plus de démocratie
qu'ils soient liés au territoire pour
mettre en place une sobriété à plus
grande échelle
et alors le problème c'est que pour tout
ça il faut du temps il faut du temps
pour s'informer du temps pour être
acteur et être un citoyen dans la
société civile
on nous dit aussi qu'il faut il faut du
temps aussi pour auto produire pour
avoir une partie doit dire de production
chez toi chez soi par exemple par un
potager etc
donc c'est vrai qu'il faut quand on est
dans une société où souvent en manque de
temps en tout cas t'as pas tous
forcément ce moment mais d'habitude on
est plutôt dans une société qui manquent
de temps mettre en place cette
démocratie directe demanderait que les
citoyens aient du temps pour s'impliquer
dans la société au quotidien mais il ya
des exemples assaillants à madrid
des exemples comme ça il ya des mises en
place de démocratie directe est
justement les citoyens était plus
impliqué
comprenez mieux les décisions et elle
était mieux en mieux acceptée donc c'est
possible de le mettre en place comme le
reconnaît pierre rabhi dans votre
dernier livre vivre mieux sans
croissance
une société ne peut pas changer si les
hommes qui la composent ne change pas
comment ôter univers changer alors ça
moi je moi ce journaliste donc mon rôle
c'est d'informer
donc moi j'essaye vraiment bien sûr
c'est des enquêtes engagées mais
j'essaye toujours de distinguer au
maximum l'opinion de fait de recroiser
les informations donner une information
sur ces moi j'ai l'impression c'est de
cette façon là je me dis les gens ils
vont être informés ils vont changer
pierre rabhi va le faire d'une autre
façon moi je vous dis de ma façon vous
savez bien que ça fait 37 pardonne nous
interrompt
ça fait 30 ans qu'on a dit qu'on doit
changer que cette transition écologique
était indispensable que le réchauffement
climatique nous mène tout ça notre perte
qui va falloir arriver à cette sobriété
donc vous parler en 30 ans mais très
très peu changé par la méthode douce
donc d'où la nécessité pour certains
déjà d'instaurer des mesures plus
draconiennes plus drastiques qui
ressemble un poste on connaît
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de liberté
qui sont sacrifiés pour la sécurité dans
la sécurité sanitaire
demain ça pourrait être lé sécurité
environnementale quoi qu'il arrive il
faut beaucoup de policiers pour la faire
respecter
non mais c'est sûr que là aujourd'hui
tous les types et on parle beaucoup du
réchauffement climatique mais aussi la
pollution des sols la pollution de l'eau
il ya tout tout l'environnement et là on
parle de crise sanitaire mais pour moi
c'est aussi une ville écologique
je pense qu'on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
des causes mais vraiment labeur j'ai pas
mal l'enquêté la salle dernières
semaines là dessus et la baisse de la
biodiversité a un rôle vraiment très
important sur l'augmentation du nombre
des fidèles me donc pour moi on est déjà
dans une crise écologique là aujourd'hui
on ne sait on sait déjà une crise
écologique aujourd'hui donc on l'a vu
déjà en fait mais là ont été les
conséquences ont construit pas une autre
société
donc oui bien sûr qu'il va falloir avoir
un état qui soit par exemple plus
hermétique aux lobbys 60 pour 71% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le monde sont dus à 100 multinationales
depuis 1988
donc bien sûr qu'il faut un état puis
puissants notamment est plus hermétique
aux lobbies de toutes sortes
il y aura certainement de certainement
des mesures qui vont pas plaire à tous
parce qu'il va falloir les mettre en
place et qui aura une part de sobriété
mais si on est dans un ce serait un tout
autre modèle s'il faut mettre en place
je dis pas que ça va moi je suis je ne
dis pas que ça va arriver deux mois ça
va se mettre en place en 5 minutes c'est
pas simple à mettre en place mais quand
vous dites que bienvenu en haletant au
grunge qu'on peut se mettre en place
très rapidement puisque là il ya la
moitié de l'humanité est confiné les
libertés publiques sont réduites à abuja
et ça s'est fait en très très peu de
temps on voit bien le numérique le
mérite de l'état d'urgence de la
situation exceptionnelle deux pas de la
réduction des libertés du sacrifice de
la liberté en général à quoi il faudrait
ajouter la fiche du confort
le ch a créé fils de la liberté d'aller
et venir aussi
on l'a sacrifié la sacrifier demain mais
où là en tout cas moi dans le langage
que j'ai réalisé et ce que j'ai vu sur
le terrain en allant rencontrer les gens
de la société civile qui inventent déjà
d'autres d'auto de mode de vie qui sont
des croissants qui sont avec plus de
sobriété qui sont différents à leur a
pas du tout imposé et ils ont créé
d'autres façons de faire et je pense que
cette société elle vous dit depuis 20
ans ça ça n'a pas beaucoup évolué et
certes il ya la consommation elle
continue de croître mais il ya quand
même beaucoup d'initiatives dans la
société civile est partout dans le monde
qui sont mis en place pour d'autres
modèles de développement dans cette
enquête j'ai même été en mauritanie où
le fonds de dotation qui ravit met en
place un village tout écologique où
j'essaye de faire différemment en france
il ya plein de lieux où on essaye de
faire différemment et il manque
aujourd'hui le problème c'est que l'état
a plutôt tendance à empêcher ces
initiatives de la société civile plutôt
que les porter donc c'est ça qui manque
en fait aujourd'hui aujourd'hui a
énormément d'initiatives qui sont
partout en france partout dans le monde
pour essayer de mettre une autre
un autre modèle qui n'est pas et moi je
le répète en tout cas ce cas c'est un
un constat que j'ai réalisé c'est que
c'est pas le même partout justement cédé
que c'est souvent des modèles qui sont
sur des territoires avec des grands
principes mais mais aujourd'hui il
manque le relais étatique c'est à dire
que ces initiatives en l autre à l temps
souvent elles ont moins dead on voit
bien que l'agriculture biologique
souvent à moins d'être c'est compliqué
pour les agriculteurs de passer à la
transition de passer de d'avoir des
ailes pour passer à l'agriculture avec à
l'agroécologie enfin au web c'est plutôt
l'inversé et à n'être pas toutes ces
initiatives de la société civile il
faudrait plutôt les aider pour pas
justement passer à quelque chose ce qui
va être moi ce qui me semble important
c'est que dans ce nouveau mot de ce
nouveau mode de vie où ces nouveaux
modes d'existence mais il faut trouver
là je place juste de l'état c'est-à-dire
faut pas que ce soit justement une
dictature mais il faut pas non plus
qu'il ait pas de grands principes
nationaux et qu'on retourne dans des
choses traditionnelles avec que dès que
du local et souvent ça ça peut être un
peu comparable avec la gestion de l'eau
la gestion de l'eau c'est souvent une
gestion qui est faite sur les
territoires
mais il faut des grands principes
nationaux ou des grands principes
internationaux bâle et il faut trouver
je voudrais tous vous voir un nouvel
équilibre mais c'est pas la place nature
de l'état donc ça serait une nouvelle
place de l'état qui serait là pour
encourager toutes les initiatives de la
société civile mais ce soit pas lui qui
soit qui dise comment on va devoir faire
c'est un nouveau un nouvel équilibre à
trouver
je dis pas que c'est simple moi je dis
pas du tout que c'est samedi juste que
en tout cas quand on va sur le terrain
on voit qu'il ya énormément
d'initiatives qui sont mises en place je
suis pas je sais pas du tout si ça ça va
se faire j'aimerais bien mais en tout
cas on peut et on peut souhaiter qu avec
cette cette crise actuelle qui pour qui
pour moi être déjà une crise écologique
sanitaire économique humaine globale
on pourrait saisir cette opportunité
pour changer le système mais changer car
vraiment le logiciel en fait du système
de façon plus globale et on pourrait
mettre en place et il a il ya vraiment
énormément de gens de la société civile
qui en ce moment m des tribunes par tous
ont envie ça change quand même il ya
emma +40 et de vouloir changer le modèle
et on pourrait imaginer un espèce de
plan marshall comme on a fait après la
seconde guerre mondiale où on
investirait pour convertir totalement en
agroécologie où il y aurait de la
rénovation pour les bâtiments où on
mettra en place mon soutiendrait tout ce
qui est ses modèles de l'économie
sociale et solidaire qui souvent sont
ancrés sur les territoires où d'autres
façons d'entreprendre ou l'objectif de
l'entreprise n'est pas toujours de
croître indéfiniment mais souvent
d'esmée et de deux tonnes d'aidé après
d'autres entrepreneurs à créer leur
entreprise sans que ce soit toujours
centré sur le profit complètement
réformé la financiers tant qu on
réformera pas la finance en n'arrivera
pas à changer notre modèle parce que
aujourd'hui c'est toute une bataille d
c'est totalement disproportionnée alors
le chiffre date de 2010 2017 mais la
taille du secteur bancaire européen et
trois fois et demie plus important que
les que le pays le pib européen donc ce
sont des c'est totalement
disproportionné en fait donc il y en a
énormément de choses à faire on a un
chantier énorme mais on a de la chance
et qu'on a énormément de chercheurs ont
fait plein de travaux magnifique qui
nous montre déjà la voie et on à
esnandes acteurs de la société civile
les associations etc qui agissent au
quotidien partout en france et partout
dans le monde pourrait pour inventer un
autre modèle et ça marche
c'est à dire l'agroécologie ça marche
pour nourrir la planète les modèles de
l'économie sociale et solidaire ça
fonctionne pour pour réussir à se passer
de de financement boursier essayer de
faire dit
faire un an ça fonctionne donc voilà
c'est pas de ce serait faut supprimer
les excès de la finance sipa de
supprimer toute la finance mais
d'inventer d'autres modèles il ya des la
société civile le met déjà en place
depuis très longtemps donc il faudrait
juste basculer à ce modèle là je dis pas
que c'est simple un mois je suis
journaliste je constate je sais que sur
le terrain de voir ce qui est fait de
redonner au dos voilà mon donner les
informations qui me paraissent
essentiels je dis pas que c'est simple
mais je dis que ce serait très différent
de ce qu'on vit actuellement qui est un
monde confiné total pas du tout pour
viviane centré sur l'ordinateur le
numérique est donc là on peut même pas
se rencontrer on se parle à travers un
ordinateur et à c'est moi c'est pas du
tout la société que je souhaite pour
demain c'est horrible d'être au filet
chez soit pas pouvoir sortir d'avoir
peur de l'autre rien que en se déplaçant
enfin moi c'est pas du tout le modèle et
et les modèles que j'ai rencontrés à
travers les enquêtes
j'ai bon pour notre bilan carbone c'est
bon bilan carbone on voit que les
animaux sauvages
il va alors je sais je connais pas va
vérifier l'origine des images qu'on voit
partout sur les réseaux sociaux je sais
pas si elles sont elles sont tout juste
mais on voit que la nature reprend en
tout cas ses droits à certains endroits
donc oui c'est bon c'est une conséquence
positive encore que le numérique c'est
pas trés trés toujours très le monde
comme on l'utilisé je sais que voilà
changer parce que je savais aussi des
conséquences mais c'est bon mais c'est
pas du tout c'est plutôt une conséquence
du modèle actuel et là on est beaucoup
sur les conséquences mais faudrait
revenir aux courses pour pouvoir changer
notre modèle en profondeur mais si
juliette rappel le titre du livre que
vous voulez publier les carabines vivre
mieux sans croissance
c'est dans votre collection carnets d'
alerte qui est sorti aux presses du
châtelet
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
portez vous bien
[Musique]